So, I want to pick up in December the 8th, 1923, and this is Volume 16.
This is on the Immaculate Conception of the Virgin, and how she was conceived in the Merit's
works and pains of the Encarnate Word.
I was thinking about the Immaculate Conception of my Queen Mother, and after I received Holy
Communion, my Beloved Jesus made himself seen in my interior, that's your Luke 1721.
As though inside a room, which is a space, which was all light, which is one Timothy
616, God lives an unapproachable light.
In this light, he showed everything he had done during the course of his life.
Now, notice that everything is present, and once he brings her into this light, she can
see everything, because it's all there.
One could see, lined up in order, all his merits, his works, his pains, his wounds,
and his blood, everything that the life of a man and God contained.
As though in the act of preserving a soul so very dear to him from the slightest evil
that could possibly shadow her.
So in this light, she sees everything, and therefore she can see what happens in the
conception of Blessed Mother, it's all present.
Louisa said, "I was amazed at seeing so much attention of Jesus, and he said to me, 'To
my little newborn, I want to make known the Immaculate Conception of the Virgin conceived
without sin.'"
Now, first of all, you must know that my divinity is one single act.
To me, that's the fiat.
Now, the scientists call this a singularity.
It's one single point.
Everything is there, past, present, and future, a singularity is what they call it.
So the scientists are getting very, very close to actually naming the singularity, and they've
got even further—I watched this to see it on the science programs—they've got even
further—they said, "Someone has to be behind the big bang."
And I said, "Well, aren't you getting there?"
Now, we could tell you, but you've got to find out for yourself.
So my divinity is one single act.
All acts concentrate in a single act.
All acts in the divine will are in that one act.
Okay.
So this is what it means to be God, the greatest portant of our divine essence, not to be subject
to a succession of acts, and we've got to make lots of acts.
He makes one.
And if, to the creature, it seems that we do something now, and then we do something else,
it's rather that we make known what is present in our single act.
We're inside of time and space.
He's outside of time and space.
So it's just simply manifested to us.
He makes it known.
In fact, since the creature is incapable of knowing it all at once, we make it known little
by little.
Now, we've proved that in our educational system, we only give children information
piece by piece and year on year, and it's the same—Jesus has told us it's the same
in the divine will.
He only gives it to a sip by sip, because you couldn't take it all in.
Now, everything that I, the eternal word, was to do in my assumed humanity, formed one
single act.
So the whole point here is God is one act.
So it formed one single act with that single act of my—which my divinity contains.
So his humanity is now one single act in that one single act of the divinity.
Therefore, before this noble creature was conceived, everything that the divine word
was to do upon earth already existed, okay?
The pre-existent word and the pre-existent word is all over the Old Testament, okay?
So I'm not going to give you one reference for it.
It's all over the place.
I have a set of CDs on the subject.
And so in the act in which this virgin was conceived, all of my merits, my pains, my
blood—you need to get a chair up here—everything that the life of the man God—we'd say the
man God, not a man and God, as if it was to the man God—contained, lined up around
our conception.
In other words, the gift of the fullness of redemption that was given to our blessed
mother, that we call the Immaculate Conception, were the fruits of the merits of Jesus in
his redemption.
She just got them ahead of time.
And we can say ahead of time, because we're in time.
Everything is eternal with God—excuse me a second.
So everything lined up around our conception, and she was conceived in the endless abysses
of my merits.
Now look at the words.
The endless abysses of Jesus' merits means that he could have redeemed millions of worlds
because all of his acts were infinite or infinite, perfect, and eternal as you're used to hearing.
In the endless abysses of my merits and of my divine blood—so it wasn't just human
blood—and in the immense sea of my pain—the immense sea means immeasurable.
So everything is not just human, it's also divine.
By virtue of them, she remained Immaculate.
That means that she benefited more from redemption than anybody else.
No matter what canonized saints we have, none of them could have received as much redemption
as she did, because she had it full and complete.
So it's true to say that he died more for her than anybody else, since she benefited
the most from it.
She remained Immaculate, beautiful, and pure.
My incalculable merits barred the enemy's way, and he could do no harm to her, so she's
protected from the very first instance of her being.
It was right that the one who was to conceive the Son of God first be conceived in the works
of this God—this is terribly important—that she was conceived in him before he was conceived
of her.
All the saints have talked about that.
So beside that I want to give you one Corinthians 4-7, what have you that you have not received?
Because as a creature, she had to receive everything from God in order to be able to
give it to him.
So she had to first be conceived in the works of this God, to be able to have the power of
conceiving that word who was to come to redeem mankind.
So first, she was conceived in me—this is exactly what the saints have said—and then
I was conceived in her.
There was nothing left but to make it known to the rest of humanity at the appropriate
time.
And in the divinity it was as though already done—wonderful stuff, isn't it?
Therefore, the one who most gathered the fruits of redemption, or rather who received its complete
fruit, was this excelling creature.
Having been conceived in the divine will, she loved, she esteemed, and she kept as her
own, everything that the Son of God did upon the earth.
O the beauty of this tender little one, she was a prodigy of grace, a portent of our
divinity.
She grew up as our daughter.
She was our decorum, our joy, our honor, and our glory.
That's exactly what the Church sang of her until we dropped the Latin.
You are the glory of Jerusalem, the joy of Israel, and the honor of our people.
While my sweet Jesus was saying this, I was thinking in my mind, "It's true that the
Queen Mother was conceived in the endless merits of my Jesus, but her blood, her body,
were conceived in the womb of Saint Anne."
Now, I love the way Louisa doesn't let him away with anything, and she comes back with
her own reasoning.
And so, Saint Anne was not a joy comment, Anne were not exempt from original sin.
So she wants to know how a child could be born of two people who had original sin and
not have original sin.
Louisa is asking our question.
She's actually asking our question.
She doesn't need this herself.
So how can it be that she inherited nothing of the many evils that we've all inherited
from the sin of our first father, Adam?
So here's a very important answer from Jesus.
Jesus said, "My daughter, you've not yet understood that all evil is in the will."
Now, I think you need to put a green, white and gold marker on that one.
All evil is in the will.
In all the volumes up to now, you've heard Jesus saying to Louisa when she's struggling,
"Don't put your will into it."
You've heard him say it over and over again, "Okay, you're struggling and your body wants
to be resentful, don't put your will into it."
The priests have been very hard on you and your body wants to react, "Don't put your
will into it.
The sin is in the will."
It's not very interesting.
It was the will that overwhelmed man and that is his human nature.
It simply says his nature here, it means his human nature.
It was not his human nature that overwhelmed the will of man.
That's a terribly important insight into the fall of Adam, a terribly important insight.
It was not the apple that brought Adam down, if I can say something that sounds totally
stupid, it was Adam that brought the apple down.
It was Adam's will that sinned, that's terribly important.
It was not his nature that overwhelmed the will of man.
His human nature remained in its place, but the body you see has to participate in whatever
the will decides.
Not as it was created by me, nothing changed, it was his will that changed.
Did you put a VIP on this, will you?
Because you're getting an emphasis here that's terribly important for everywhere else in these
writings.
It was his will that changed.
It that is the human will put itself against no less than a divine will.
Here is the essence of the message about the human will against the divine will.
This rebellious will overwhelmed his nature, debilitated it, contaminated it, and rendered
it a slave to the most vile passions, it was the fall of the will.
So John 844, anyone who sins is a slave.
And so it rendered him a slave to vile passions, because if the will falls, then that's your
highest faculty, where do you go to try and live a healthy religious life, a moral life.
It happened, Jesus said, as to a container, now that expression, it happened as to, it's
not something that we say, we'd say it's like, it's like a container full of perfumes
or of precious things.
If it's emptied of these and then filled with rot or vile things, does the container perhaps
change?
No, the contents do.
What is placed inside of it changes, but the container is always the same.
So if you have a piece of water for glass with rot inside of it, it's still water for
a glass, the rot is still rot, okay, but you have to distinguish the two.
Now notice the way Jesus is distinguishing between the will and the human nature that's
holding that person.
What is placed inside of the container changes, but the container is always the same.
And at the most, it becomes more or less estimable, we would say, precious.
Depending on what it contains, he said, that was the same way with the human being.
Now being conceived in a creature whose, Joachim and Anne, okay, particularly Anne, from a human
race did no harm to my mother because her soul was immune from any sin.
The soul that was put into that little thing that was about to develop into a person, that
was completely protected by God.
There was no division between her will and that of her God.
So he makes it clear that what we call the immaculate conception is that the moment she
became a being, she was already completely redeemed, and her will was already cemented
in the divine will forever.
And so the fiat that she gave as an adult simply was her signature on paper, but that
was already given totally.
Her soul was immune from any sin.
There was no division between her will and that of her God.
So this is the position of Adam before the fall.
The divine currents found no obstacle or opposition in pouring themselves upon her.
In every instant, she was under the pouring rain of new graces.
Now notice the abundance that's being described there, pouring rain.
So with this will and this soul, all holy, all pure, all beautiful, the container of
her body which she received from her mother remained fragrant, rehabilitated, ordered,
divinized.
In such a way as to remain exempt also from all the natural maladies by which the human
nature is invaded.
So if she was preserved from sin, she was also preserved from the sickness and the debilitation
and everything that went with it.
Now she did go through death, but we call that her passing.
Sickness, sin, death and hell are the four consequences of the fall.
So there was nothing in her, in rebellion against herself or in rebellion against God
or in rebellion against anything else.
So there wasn't, there was no, we correctly call illness dis-ease, okay.
And it is also correctly called dis-order.
And so she never had dis-ease or dis-order.
I think that's a better way to put it, okay.
She was precisely the one who received the seed of the fiat volunteers to her on earth
as it is in heaven, which ennobled her and restored her to her origin.
There's the origin before the fall.
As man was created by us before he sinned, even more she surpassed it because of the profusion
of grace that was given to her in redemption.
She was embellished even more through the continuous flows of that fiat, which alone
has the power of reproducing images fully similar to the one who created them.
Now let me read that again.
So she had all this grace, she'd all this prevention and she had the fullness of redemption.
Now, she was embellished even more through the continuous flows of that divine will,
that divine yes that was in her, which alone has the power of reproducing images fully
similar to the one who created them.
That's Romans 8, 29, that we become the image of Christ.
Now that image was given to us initially in Genesis 1, 27.
And by virtue of this divine will that acted upon her, it can be said that what God is
by nature, she is by grace.
And if the only comment I would give you on that is that God can only make something
like himself, there is no other model.
There is no other version of reality.
He is the model.
He is the reality.
Now Louisa also tells, sorry, Jesus also tells us in these writings of Louisa that that
is what he's going, trying to do with us as well, that he's trying to make us by grace
what he is by nature.
And that will happen when we live fully 24, 7, 3, 6, 5 in the divine will as distinct
from going in and out.
So it demands this very high union with God, okay.
So what God is by nature, she is by grace.
Our will can do anything and it can reach anywhere, Mark 10, 27.
Nothing is impossible with God.
Our will can do anything and reach anywhere.
It's the kind of little thing that I like writing on a tiny little post-it note and put
it beside me where I am praying.
The divine will can do anything and reach anywhere.
It just helps you to go and actually let him do it.
It can reach anywhere when the soul gives us the freedom to act and does not interrupt
our work with our own will.
Now notice that we interrupt Ephesians 2, 10, where God's work of art created in Christ
Jesus and he will finish the work.
He will finish the work as Philippians 1, 6.
Philippians 1, 6.
He will finish the work if we don't stop him.
So December the 26th, 1923, we're going to be talking about acts in the divine will.
Louisa said, "I went through most bitter days because of the privation of my sweet Jesus.
I felt like a most wretched rag which Jesus had put aside because it was disgusting to
him.
So dirty as it was.
Isaiah 64, 6, uses exactly the same image.
And in my interior I heard being said to me, "In my will there are no rags."
How can you be a rag in the divine will when it's the highest expression of union with
God?
And everything is life, so I want to give you Romans 3, verses 10 to 11.
And it's not just life, it's divine life.
A rag is torn, it becomes dirty, because it does not have life.
While in my will, which contains life, all life comes from the divine will, and gives
life to everything, there's no danger that the soul may be torn to pieces or even get
dirty.
Now the get dirty is sin, and there's no way you can have sin in the divine will.
So you put there your Hebrews 12, 14 again, nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence
of God.
And also 1 John 3, 5, that those who are truly in union with God don't sin.
Not paying attention to this, I talked to myself, I loved when Louisa said I wasn't
paying attention, there was he talking and I wasn't paying attention.
Now that's probably our position more frequently than we want to admit, but he wouldn't be
as physically manifested to you as he was to her.
It's like you're sitting on your mother's knee or your father's knee, and he's talking
to you and you're not paying any attention, and then you ask him something completely
irrelevant.
Why weren't you listening?
That's her position, this extraordinary intimacy, and she can still switch off from it.
And I think what you're looking at is her free will, her will is completely free.
It's got to be given all the time, it's fascinating.
So she was thinking about Christmas when he was talking about that, isn't that absolutely
amazing?
It's a good time of the year to read this.
So not paying attention, I talked to myself, what beautiful Christmas holidays is Jesus
making, we spend, it shows how much he loves, this is December the 26th.
And he moving in my interior, there's your Luke 1721, said my daughter, for one who does
my will, it's always Christmas.
Now some people are so devoted to Christmas, they want it every day of the year, some of
the rest of us don't want it at all, because of what they've done with it.
It's always Christmas.
As the soul enters my will, I am conceived in her act, now watch this, so this is a comment
on Christmas.
As the soul enters my will, so we fuse, I am conceived in her act.
As she goes on performing her act, I carry out my life.
As she completes the act, I rise again, and the soul remains conceived in me, carries
out her life in mine, and rises again in my acts.
Isn't that incredible?
So what you're being talking, sorry, what is being said here is that with each act we
have a resurrection experience to divine life.
With each act we have a resurrection experience to divine life.
See then how Christmas holidays are for those who prepare themselves and place themselves
in my grace once a year.
And so they feel something new about my birth within themselves.
But for one who lives in my will, my book always says does my will.
It's always Christmas I am born again in each one of her acts.
Isn't that incredible?
So would you want me to be born in you once a year?
No, no.
For one who lives in my will, my birth, my life, my death, and my resurrection must be a continuous
act never interrupted.
Otherwise, what would be the difference, the immeasurable distance from the other sanctities?
That's lovely there, isn't that a wonderful point?
The people who are in their ordinary sanctity are celebration Christmas once a year.
You have it every time you do an act, it's absolutely fantastic, isn't it?
So we have this extraordinary privilege of the Lord being born again in us in every
act.
And so we are born again into divine life at every act.
I don't know what you do without that.
I just say to the Lord, I want to fuse myself, I say it longer than this.
I want to fuse myself in you all the time.
I don't want to break in it.
And so when I remember it again, I would say, this is for all the time.
I want this at every moment.
I don't want any break in this.
But you have to say, I think you have to repeat it for yourself, not for him.
He heard you the first time, but we can forget.
And so that's why I repeat it to myself every now and then.
I said, Lord, I want this all the time.
No break.
It must be a continuous act never interrupted.
Otherwise, if we only experience Christmas, the way other people experience Christmas,
we have not touched the-- he said immeasurable distance between ordinary sanctity and the
divine will sanctity.
Now, I'm going to talk to you in detail about that in Dromantane, because I think people
may not have got really what's being said.
It's terribly important.
So on hearing this, Louisa said, I felt more embittered.
And I thought to myself, how much fantasy this hearing is nothing other than the most
subtle pride on my part.
Only my pride would suggest this to me and reach the point of making me right so many
things on the will of God.
The others, that means all the other people living the ordinary sanctity.
The others are good and they're humble.
And that's why no one has ever dared to write anything to see.
Now, Louisa is the first with this revelation, of course she's having problems like this.
How could I be right?
And I'm seemingly saying that all of them are living at an emmeasurably low distance
from me.
It does look like pride, you see, superficially.
And so she's right in thinking this way.
And while I was thinking of this, I felt such pain as to feel my heart break and I tried
to distract myself so as not to feel anything, I loved that.
Instead of saying, what is the pain?
Why do I feel pain from having said this?
Is somebody saying he's having pain?
Okay.
What a terrible struggle to the point of feeling myself dying.
Then while I was in this state, my beloved Jesus made himself seen as though wanting
to say more about his most holy will.
But Louisa said, my Jesus helped me.
Don't you see how much pride there is in me, have pity on me, free me from this subtle
pride.
I don't want to know anything.
It's enough for me to love you.
Now, what she's saying is, look, this business is too big, it's too great.
Look, it's enough for me just to love you.
And that's escaping from the mission that's actually given to her.
It's only a temptation.
He's not going to let her away with it, of course.
I don't want to know anything.
It's enough for me to love you.
And Jesus said, my daughter crosses, sorrows, pains are like a press, a wine press, that
is for the soul.
Just as the wine press serves to crush and peel the grapes in such a way that the wine
remains on one side and the skin on the other in the same way, crosses and pains like a
press, peel the soul of pride, of love, of self, of passions, and of all that as human
leaving the pure wine of virtue behind.
Now you know why you'll never be free of crosses and pains and sufferings and cetera.
It's because this immense thing has got to happen in us, this separation of the human
and the divine.
And I want to give you Isaiah 63, 3.
And I want to give you Lamentations, L-A-M for Lamentations, Chapter 1, Verses 12 and 13.
Lamentations 1, 12 to 13.
So it's very important for us to know that if we are to reach the heights that the Lord
wants us to reach, that he has to do extraordinary work of purification in us, there's no way
out of that.
It's absolutely no way out of it.
And so my virtues find the way to communicate themselves and lay themselves within the
soul as on a snow white canvas.
Now there's your Ephesians 2, 10 again, we're a work in progress.
And he does this writing with indelible characters, now that's Jeremiah 31, 31 to 34.
I will write it on their hearts, Jeremiah 31, 31 to 34.
Now notice that the Lord wants a snow white canvas to paint on, he doesn't want a dirty
canvas or one that has any leftovers from any other painter including ourselves.
And so to get to the snow white stage we have to have the crosses and the sorrows and the
pains working like a press on us.
How can you fear then, Jesus said, "If every time I've manifested to you my truths on
my will," watch this, "these truths are always preceded by crosses, sorrows and pains."
Now we have people in the process of being trained as teacher, I just want to get a tiny
testimony here, I mean tiny as in a few sentences.
I've noticed over the years when I was preparing to give retreats or conferences abroad that
the Lord put me through a ringer before I went.
All hell would break loose to use our Irish expression.
And it would seem that the whole world was completely against me.
But being put under the press was actually the price you had to pay to be God's instrument
at that conference.
And I would arrive at the conference thinking, "I haven't got the energy to stand up."
And then the Lord would allow me to actually read what was going on inside of everybody.
I was able to actually tell them the answers to their problems and they would come to me
one after the other and say, "How did you know what my problem was?"
You answered it absolutely accurately, "I was going to sign up to talk to you."
And before the conference would be finished, all their problems would be answered.
Now, where did that come from?
It came from the crosses, sorrows, pains, and the press that was on the soul before you
went.
Is that any help?
Therefore, we need to do a lot of preparation for our coming conference.
These truths are always preceded by crosses, sorrows, and pains.
In other words, someone has to pay for the grace that is given.
And the higher the truths, the more intense and the stronger the pains.
That's what Louisa experiences as she goes along.
It was nothing other than the pressure of the press which I exercised in you in order
to peel you of all that is human.
Well, the Lord has to send stuff to us to release us from all that is human.
We just can't let it go ourselves because we think we're letting it go and we don't
know what we're letting go.
It was in my interest, he said, more than yours, that these truths would not be mixed
with the skin of human passions.
Look at the expression that's being used, the skin of human passions.
And Louisa said, "My Jesus, forgive me if I'm telling you this, but you yourself are
the cause of my fears."
In other words, it's not my fault, it's you.
If you did not leave me, if you did not hide and deprive me of yourself, there would be
no place in me to let these fears arise.
In other words, if you stayed with me and I was an ecstasy all day, every day that we
would grant, well, the rest of us would too.
And Jesus, you make me die but of cruel death and double death because I don't die.
If only I could experience death and die how sweet it would be for me.
This hurt your two Corinthians five again, two Corinthians five, one to ten.
That's St. Paul wanting to knock off the tent and go to heaven.
"Ah, Jesus," she said, "I'm telling you, I can bear no more.
Either you take me with you or you remain with me whichever you like because I'm going
to heaven one way or the other, either you're coming down or I'm going up.
Not a bad way to communicate."
Now while Louisa was saying this, Jesus clasped her in his arms and it was as if he was winding
something with his hands and she said, "I was put as though through a press crushed."
Now there she's asking him, "Listen, can I go to heaven or else heaven comes down to
heaven here?" and he gets on with doing what he's talking about which is the crosses and
the pains and the sorrows.
If I can put it this way, the surgeon gets on with the operation regardless of what the
patient is saying, does that make any sense?
"I myself am unable to tell the pain I felt within me," Louisa said.
He alone knows what he made me suffer and then afterwards he told me, "Beloved daughter
of my will, look inside of me, how my supreme will conceded not even a breath of life to
the will of my humanity."
So Jesus is saying, "Look to me, I'm the model."
Not one breath was allowed to the will that was in my humanity.
As holy as this will in Jesus' humanity was, not even that was conceded to me.
I was to remain under the pressure of a divine, infinite, endless will.
Now we're going to hear more and more about that as we go on, as Louisa goes, more and
more under the pressure of a divine, infinite, endless will, more than a press, which constituted
itself the life of each one of my heartbeats.
Now notice that this infinite divine will constituted itself the life of everything in
Jesus, his very heartbeat.
Not only that, it was the life of all my words and all my acts and my little human will died
in each heartbeat, breath, act, word, et cetera, but it died in reality.
It's the bit that we don't seem to think can happen.
It died in reality, he said.
It actually felt death because it never had life.
Now Jesus had to do this to pay the price for all of us to be able to rise in the divine
will and to have the grace to put aside our own will.
I had my human will only to make it die continuously.
And even though this was a great honor for my humanity and the greatest of portents, each
death of my human will was substituted by a life of the divine will.
Now notice each time you do it, you create a divine life.
See it?
Each time you set aside the human will and let the divine will take over, create a divine
life.
However, this continuous dying was the greatest, the hardest, the most bitter and the most
painful martyrdom of my humanity, which ever put in be or something one foot tall beside
that.
If Jesus found it the hardest sacrifice to make, that is why you and I find it the hardest
sacrifice to make.
Oh how the pains of my passion become little before this continuous dying of mine expressed
very well in Gethsemane when he was under terrible pressure, not my will but dying be
done.
And in this alone, I completed the perfect glory of my celestial father.
So he's telling us how we can give perfect glory to the heavenly father by making the
human will die and let the divine will take over.
And I loved him with the love that surpasses any other love of all creatures.
Look at that.
I loved him with the love that surpasses any other love of all creatures.
To die, to suffer, to do something great a few times at intervals, that's not very
great.
Oh dear.
Whichever put a marker on that one, because I don't know about you but some of us might
be there, that you can do it every now and then.
You might even do it every now and then every day, but not all the time.
It's that all the time, the continuous thing.
So he says, "To do it every now and then, it's not so great."
The saints, the good, and other creatures have also worked, suffered, and died.
That's John 1412.
My disciples will do the same work as I did, John 1412.
So the saints, the good, and the other creatures also have worked, have suffered, have died.
But since it was not a continuous suffering, doing, and dying, it constitutes neither a
perfect glory to the Father, nor a redemption that can be extended to all.
In other words, it's limited.
"Therefore, my newborn daughter in my eternal will, see now where your Jesus calls you and
once you."
That's in this continuous martyrdom, "Under the press of my divine will, so that your
will may receive continuous death, just as my human will did.
Otherwise, I could not make the new era arise.
Somebody has to do it continuously."
So the new era can't arise unless Louisa actually reaches this point, in which my will
may come to reign upon the earth.
It takes the continuous act.
Now that's something the Lord's putting in front of you tonight.
The continuous act in the divine will.
The continuous killing of the human will, not my will, but thine be done.
I think that has to be the martyr.
Some people just simply say fiat, fiat, but that actually doesn't do it for me.
I have to say not my will, but thine be done.
To make it absolutely clear, one is going, the other is being chosen.
And it's very good to say it when things are going against you, and human nature would
like to fight back.
It might like to assert its own rights, and you may even be right, but it's in the moments
of trial and the cross, that that's where it becomes very, very, very grace-filling.
Not my will, but thine be done.
And it can happen in very small things.
It doesn't have to be great things, because I think everyday life is made up of small things
rather than big things.
Otherwise you said, oh yeah, it takes the continuous act, I'm going to repeat this, continuous
pains, continuous death, in order to be able to snatch the fiat Belontus to a from heaven.
So this is VIP now, be where my daughter do not look at others.
Do not look at my other saints.
Why?
No matter how great they were, they were living a spirituality that was much lower than what
you were being asked to live.
Do you see where you can distract yourself?
Do not look at the way I conducted myself with them, many of them worked miracles, many
of them did this and that and the other day they did marvelous things for God.
He said, don't look at that, I'm doing something different with you.
But we like looking at other people, don't we?
And we like being as good as the Joneses, you know?
And we like to feel that if they can work a miracle, I can work a miracle.
That's S-E-L-F, isn't it?
So do not look at others, that's why I asked you to put a VIP on this one.
Don't look at my other saints, don't look at the way I conducted myself with them, which
causes you to be surprised at the way I behave with you.
This is a new spirituality, it's a new way of life, it's a new way of God dealing with
us and it can be difficult for us to let go of the past and bring it to the future.
So I want to give you Isaiah 43 verses 18 and 19 where the Lord says, let the past go,
I'm doing a new thing, Isaiah 43 verses 18 and 19.
With them I wanted to do one thing, but with you I wanted to do something completely different.
So if you go on YouTube and you're seeing that other people are working great, miracles
are doing this, that and the other, that's not what he's doing with you, he's doing something
completely different.
And if we concentrate on what he's doing with us, then his will can be done.
And if I want to be like them and do this, that's me interfering, okay?
And it's just a great temptation of ours, you hear somebody working great miracles say,
well I'm not doing anything, I'm useless, and you're not looking at what he's actually
asking you to do.
So we have to come to the conclusion and I would think you should write it down on the
page that divine will spirituality is completely different from all other spiritualities.
See because if I want to remind, if I want to remember something, I'll actually write
it on the book, divine will spirituality is completely different.
And Jesus says it's immeasurably greater than what was on offer before now.
He says it, it's not just me.
So as Jesus was saying this, he took the form of the crucified and he leaned his forehead
on mine, Louisa said, laying himself over my whole person and I remained under his pressure
and all a prey to his divine will.
So what we've just read now needs an enormous amount of attention individually.
But let's come to December 29, 1923.
In Jesus and the soul who lives in his will, there is an eternal bond which renders them
inseparable.
Now you've heard in the writings up to now Jesus and his mother are inseparable, Jesus
and Louisa have become inseparable.
And then he's saying, this has all been revealed to you.
Not to tell you that something great happened to them is that he wants you to get to that
place as well.
Is that amazing?
Okay.
So this is not just for us to throw a bouquets at them, it's to take the same journey.
Louisa said, I was praying when I found myself outside of myself in a place where there was
a crucifix cast to the ground.
I placed myself near it to a door and kissed Jesus as most holy wounds.
But when I was doing this, the crucifix came alive and Jesus on nailed his hands from the
cross and clung to my neck, clutching me very tightly.
Fearing that it might not be Jesus, I tried to free myself from those clutches and Jesus
said, my daughter, why do you want to run away from me?
How is it?
Do you want to leave me?
Don't you know that between you and me, there is an eternal bond.
That means it can't be broken because there is no point in wriggling, it's an eternal
bond.
And it binds us together such that neither you nor I can detach ourselves.
In other words, God has attached himself in this bond to Louisa and he will not break
a bond.
You know from your study of the Old Testament, he doesn't break any bonds that he makes.
We're the ones who break bonds, it's an eternal bond.
In fact he said, what is eternal enters into me, now really note this, this is extremely
important.
What is eternal enters into me and becomes inseparable from me?
Now if I was to give you that very simple English, it is that you go back to your source
from which you came and you cannot separate from that.
That is your destiny.
We are, each one of us is a spark that came out from the divine fire and we've got to
go back as a spark into that fire.
You know and so if we make this bond with the Lord and he agrees to this inseparable
bond, that's it, it's complete.
But the incredible thing is that when you die, you enter heaven with that eternal bond.
It's utterly amazing.
In fact what is eternal enters into me and becomes inseparable from me.
All the acts we have done together in my will are eternal acts.
Just as my will is eternal.
So you have something of your own in me, they're all the acts you've done.
And I have of my own in you because the divine will and the human will have actually married
in union.
An eternal vein flows within you which renders us inseparable.
And the more you continue and multiply your acts in my will, the more you take part in
what is eternal.
That's why it's important for us to multiply our acts to infinity.
I always say to him, I want to multiply the acts to infinity for an infinitude of time.
In other words it covers every second of time and then it eternally as well.
So where do you want to go Jesus said?
I was waiting for you to come and relieve me and free me from this place into which the
human perpody, now perpody are human wills absolutely diametrically opposed to the divine.
In which human perpody has cast me and with hidden sins and secret evils have barbarously
crucified me.
Now I want to give you two Thessalonians two seven.
Saint Paul calls hidden sins and secret evils the mystery of iniquity that works away in
the human race.
And one of the things that Jesus does not only to Louisa but we've been reading it in Ezekiel
and in Jeremiah and other prophets as well, that he reveals the secrets that are going
on in hidden places.
He reveals the secret sins of the leaders of both church and state and the Lord has been
doing that for quite a long time in the church now as well, revealing to the world what has
been going on secretly.
He doesn't want anything if he leaves things in secret it's like leaving a cancer festering
in your body and it will just go to completion it will kill.
But if he exposes it he himself said anything that's brought out into the light can be healed
if it's brought out into the light.
And so that's the reason why the church has been disgraced in front of humanity to get
the post out that's all.
So the hidden sins and the secret evils are the deadly stuff that kills the church.
So this is why I clung to you now this clinging of Jesus to Louisa last night we were doing
a text in volume 11 it's just this moment I don't remember the date in which Jesus said
that the people who live in the divine will are his staffs.
He deliberately used the word staff now any of you who have done the book of Exodus know
that the walking stick that Moses used which had a curly head on it was called the staff
of Moses and God told him that this was now going to become a sign and he was going to
work all his miracles staff in hand in the end the Lord just simply says staff in hand
and go ahead and work the miracle that the staff became you leaning on the power of God
you leaning on the authority of God.
So when Moses had to open the Red Sea for example the Lord said staff in hand the power
of God will do this okay.
But in volume 11 Jesus was saying to Louisa that the people who live in the divine will
are his staffs and he wants to lean on us and this is what you're getting here that
he says to Louisa but didn't you know I would come to lean on you lean on you means that
you would do the reparation I'd show you what was wrong you would do the reparation you'd
make up for God's glory you'd fill in the voids that's okay it's just the connection
between the two and that's the advantage of teaching several books at the same time.
So Louisa then he said this is why I clung to you you see that she's his staff at STAFF
that you might free me and take me with you so Louisa said I clashed into myself I kissed
him and found myself with him in my little room and I could see in between me and Jesus
how my interior was centralized in him this is the union and he was centralized in me.
So naturally enough he would come to her looking for reparation or whatever else.
Afterwards Louisa said I received holy communion and according to my usual way I was calling
on all creation is going to do around now is that okay the rest of this paragraph the
whole of this paragraph is around I was calling on all creation things placing them around
Jesus so that all might surround him like a crown and give him return of love and homage
see she's acting like the staff now he came to her to lean on her and then she acts like
the staff if you write down acts like like the staff and just say CF volume 11 because
it was in volume 11 that he told us that he would come to us that we would give him the
praise and glory and everything that the others are not giving.
So I was calling on all created things placing them around Jesus so that all might surround
him like a crown and give him love and homage to their creator.
They all ran at my call and I could see in clear notes all the love of my Jesus for me
in all of these creative things Jesus waited with such great tenderness of love within my
heart the return of so much love and I hovering over everything and embracing everything would
bring myself to the feet of Jesus and say to him my love my Jesus you have created everything
for me and you've given it to me as a gift therefore everything is mine and I give it
to you in order to love you now before I go on I just want to put CF look up John 17 because
in the priestly prayer of Jesus in John 17 Jesus speaks to the Father like this you've
given everything to me and now I give them back to you and this is what he teaches here
in this round so you've given everything to me and as a gift and I give them back to you
and so I say to you I love you in each drop of light of the sun I love you in the twinkling
of the stars so you can see where I got that in the rounds of creation that I gave you
I love you in each drop of water your love makes me see your I love you for me even in
the depths of the ocean and I impress my I love you for you in every fish that darts
in the sea I want to impress my I love you on the flight of each bird I love you everywhere
my love I want to impress my I love you upon the wings of the wind I love that expression
in the moving of the leaves and every spark of fire I love you for myself and for all
ok so the whole of creation was with me saying I love you but when I wanted to embrace all
human generations in the eternal volition to have all prostrate themselves before Jesus
so that all might fulfill the duty of saying I love you to Jesus in each one of their acts
words and thoughts they would escape me you'd never guess why would you and I would get
lost and I would not know how to do it so I said to Jesus and he said yet my daughter
the living in my will is precisely this to bring the whole of creation before me is something
as a very important teaching what is the living in the divine will consist of it's to bring
the whole of creation before me and in the name of all to give me a return of their duties
no one must escape you otherwise my will would find some voids in the creation and would not
be satisfied but do you know why you do not find everyone and that many escape you it
is the force of the free will however I want to teach you the secret of where you can find
them all enter into my humanity to see the all human beings are in the humanity of Jesus
and the church is the mystical body of Christ okay and he you'll be told several times in
the hours of the passion that we're all part of him so when we enter into his humanity
and into his divinity we can find them but if we make the mistake of just entering into
his divinity without going through the humanity as well you won't find them is that okay so
he says enter into my humanity and into my divinity so I want to teach you the secret
of where you find them all enter into my humanity and in it you will find all of their acts
as though held in custody which I took on the commitments to satisfy for on their behalf
before for my celestial father you must keep following all of my I want to teach you the
secret of where you can find all human beings enter into my humanity and in it you will find
all of their acts as though held in custody which I took on the commitment to satisfy for
on their behalf before my celestial father you must keep following all of my acts which
were the acts of all and in this way you will find everything and will give me the return
of love for everyone and for everything you can only do it through him with him and in
him as the church has already always taught us through him with him and in him everything
is in me having done it for all in me is the deposit of everything and I render to my divine
father the duty of love for all and to ever wants it can use it as the way through which
to ascend to heaven so we go through the humanity through the divinity and in Jesus we find
everyone and everything okay now so Luisa immediately said I entered into Jesus and with
ease I found everything and everyone so I entered into his humanity as well as entering
his dimininity and following the works of Jesus I would say I love you in each thought
of the creature see see where I got that as well I love you on the flight of each gaze
I love you in the sound of a word I love you in each heartbeat breath and affection I love
you in each drop of blood and in each work and in each step but who can say all that I
would do and say she only gives you an example many things one is not able to say even more
whatever one can say is said very poorly compared to the way it is said when one is together
with Jesus and then while saying I love you I found myself inside of myself okay I think
that's an appropriate place to stop.